hello my name is kevin kelly and i'm the
co-chair of the long nile foundation
for 25 years long now has been promoting
long-term thinking and we asked
ourselves who might know
about how to think long-term and we
looked around and realized that some of
the longest lived companies
and other institutions on this planet
may have something
to say about thinking long term
alexander rose the executive director of
the lung now
was employee number one and for 25 years
alexander has been thinking about this
question
recently alexander launched the
organizational
continuity project to investigate this
premise
in a systematic way
even though the project has just
launched and we're just beginning
already the question is
really productive and is prompting new
insights
this evening alexander will report on
the genesis
of that project its framework and what
we might expect in the future
i think this is a very exciting work and
at the core of the lung now foundation's
own premise to foster long-term thinking
i look forward to it and i really
welcome alexander
hello i'm alexander rose the executive
director here at the long now foundation
and today i'm going to be talking to you
about a new research project that we've
been working on called the
organizational continuity project
and the goal is really to start to
understand uh some of the
reasons behind the longest lived
organizations in terms of
how they've lasted why they've lasted
and if there's any portable lessons that
we might learn
as an institution that ourselves wants
to become
a multi-century multi-millennial
organization
the lung now foundation was started
almost 25 years ago
really to be the seed of a very
long-term institution that could survive
alongside
some of our more iconic projects like
the 10 000 year clock that's currently
under construction
or language projects like the rosetta
disc and each of these projects will
have a
hopefully a multi-thousand-year
component and we want an institution
that can both help contextualize that in
civilization
as well as maintain it and really help
maintain the information
and knowledge of civilization as it
moves through
centuries and millennia so in order to
create that institution
we realize there really aren't kind of
bodies of knowledge of creating
multi-generational institutions but
there are many of them out in the world
that we can learn from
so this project is hopefully us learning
about how to become one of the longest
term institutions ourselves and what
you're seeing here in this presentation
is the beginning of that research where
we're starting to learn about
some of these oldest organizations and
some of the reasons that they've
uh that they've been able to last it's
an interesting question of why does
organizational continuity matter
the thing that we keep coming to is that
we as society
discover things that are that are really
important information
and stories about how to better survive
something like a natural disaster and i
think
an interesting example in recent times
was the earthquake
that started a what's now considered to
be about once in
century event of a major tsunami there
back in 2011 and
when those stories of that tsunami the
tragic story of those tsunamis was going
around
this one really caught my eye and it was
a story of these
tablets and markers that were found
throughout japan some as old as 500
years old
or more reading things like high
dwellings are the peace and harmony of
our descendants remember
the calamity of the great tsunamis do
not build homes below this point
and tragically many homes were built
below this point
many homes and and property damage and
lives were lost and you know the
fukushima nuclear plant damaged
all of these things because they weren't
listening and didn't have the
organizational continuity even in a
country
that is famous for some of the best
organizational continuity
and maintenance in the world such as
japan and
you know we're now living through one of
the great examples
of um why organizational continuity
might matter it's a you know this global
pandemic
that was 100 predicted and known event
was going to happen we have
within our our own written history many
indications of it we even had
institutions that tried to prepare for
this but actually the governments didn't
listen to those and now we have this
tragic response to
you know an event that really could have
been solved better by having better
organizational continuity so this
this problem is not an esoteric one it
does it's one that that really has real
world consequences and
you know we don't want to find ourselves
you know just a generation from now
or you know 10 years from now looking at
you know down the barrel of something
like an asteroid impact again
100 predictable event that we know is
going to cause loss of life
um damage to the to infrastructure um
could cause
a total extinction level event where for
the first time we're a space-faring
species that can both predict these
events and stop them but only if we're
well prepared and we have the
organizational continuity
within our governments our private
institutions and our science community
in order to solve these types of large
problems
so what are some of the world's oldest
institutions
one of the oldest companies that we know
of is a temple construction company
called congo gumi
which was started at the end of the 6th
century at least
and is still operating today now i
believe it's been subsumed by a larger
construction conglomerate but they're
still building temples and still
largely the same kind of operations and
staff one of the oldest hotels in the
world
also in japan the nishiyama onsen
kind of a japanese homestay still in
operation today
one of the oldest restaurants in the
world built in
a little after 800 a.d as the stiff
skeller st
peter hotel and restaurant
one of the oldest wineries that we know
of in the world interestingly is
the staff elter hof winery in germany
built in 862
as far as we know some of the other
types of businesses and operations that
we start to see
over a millennia ago that are still in
operation
are bars and pubs so sean's bar
in ireland is said to have been built in
a.d the other thing that we start to see
in the 11th century
is the invention and proliferation of
universities so we have things like the
university of bologna
and uh soon afterwards the university of
oxford and then many of the other
universities in
in the uk and other parts of europe
really start to proliferate
more recently we are seeing some more
commodity type things
like the poland salt mines in welliska
starting in the 13th century and then
even paper companies like the story and
so
finished paper company in 1288 but
you'll notice that not only are many of
the oldest
organizations in the world in certain
areas like japan and
old world europe but also they tend to
be a ton of breweries
winemakers confectionaries in some cases
hotels
organizations that serve basic human
needs one of the other things that you
start to see when you look at
aggregates of companies that for
instance last for more than 200 years a
huge majority era in japan so this idea
that location matters even though japan
has risen and fallen and had lost wars
they their basic system of government
and
culture has lasted over time and and the
other places like old world europe and
germany and holland and france are some
of the other places that we see some of
the longest lived institutions
and so the other thing that you start to
see is that 90
of the companies that are over 200 years
old also
have less than 300 employees now if you
look at more modern companies like the
fortune 500 companies
another very interesting thing starts to
appear
one is that they're kind of financial
service companies there's kind of
universal services that people have
needed over the past few centuries
but if you also look at how long
companies are lasting on the fortune 500
list
it used to be in 1950 that all the
companies on the fortune 500 list
averaged at about 61 years old if you
look at that data now
that's actually less than 18 years that
these companies are surviving
so these are not mega companies they're
not the largest companies or
organizations in the world
they're the ones that have figured out a
niche and a market size
and a size of their company that can
last over centuries at a time
the thing that comes out of this data if
your only goal is growth
especially as a company it's very
difficult for you to last
for a long time you kind of outgrow all
of your resources and all of your
customers
of the thousand companies that we know
of that are over 300 years old as i
mentioned there's a huge section of this
is in the alcohol industry by a lot
the hotel industry and restaurant and
food food service industry all of which
are kind of in a way kind of the same
market and then as you get down into
this you start to find things like
pharmaceutical companies
financial companies you also find things
like libraries and universities
so i think libraries are very
interesting because they are the place
where
civilization stores its information
to help it understand problems of the
past
solutions for the future and they are
the memory
institution of our cultures and if you
look at some of the oldest libraries in
the world that are no longer in
operation
they're all largely in the middle east
but because of the historical turns of
the world
we lost many of those cities and
libraries and those libraries go back
as far as uh you know almost 4 500 years
in some cases you look at the libraries
that are still in operation
and that that whole center has moved to
europe and that's because
the organizational continuity within
europe survived a lot of those wars
and so we still have that information
we're able to um
we're able to to access it we tend to
have those languages more than we have
the languages of those ancient libraries
some of the
other oldest institutions that we have
in the world are universities
the oldest of which or at least one of
the oldest is the university at bologna
italy it was started in the 11th century
i think what's interesting about these
is that they have this property of a new
influx of students every single year
and that cycle of students this brings
new energy into the institution
but it also means that that institution
has to make itself relevant
to a different set of people every
single year so the
you know the the universities that have
lasted have done a very good job of this
their commodity is this universal one of
education but the way that they do it
has to be remarketed to every single
year
of student that they have that's helped
them last for a long time but it's also
helped remind the institution why it
matters why it's relevant
what are some of the other ways that
things have lasted for a very long time
one is to
is to have taken a very long time to
have been built
and we've mentioned religion before here
as one of the longest lasting
institutions in the world but one of
their structures that they create
are cathedrals and cathedrals have this
interesting properties that many of them
took
decades if not centuries to to build and
you know one of the oldest ones the
cathedral at cologne
uh germany was started in 1248 took 600
years to build this cathedral
the most dangerous time you find is for
something to last
is really just a generation or two after
it was first built
or founded and that's because you know
it's the institution
or the the cathedral of your of the last
generation
and it's no longer in fashion often
people find you know a different use for
that
that property um but if you take let's
say
600 years to build it by the time you're
done it's already has
a different type of value to
civilization it's a thing that has value
for its antiquity
and its cultural kind of knowledge um
and relevance and you know we see
this now with even modern cathedrals
that aren't even done so the
the sagrada familiar cathedral in
barcelona um was begun in 1882 we're now
almost 140 years into its construction
progress
and it's not done but it's already a
unesco world heritage site and there's
probably few examples of this in the
world
but if it lasts long enough even in its
build process it can become valuable to
to a civilization and that civilization
can then help it last in fact
the tickets that get sold to come into
this thing are really the way that it's
being funded
to get completed in japan we also find
things like the oldest continuously
standing wooden structures
these temples at nara japan were started
in
607 a.d and they have survived all kinds
of
influxes of government and other
societies and even other religions
to this day really because of slow
careful maintenance the roofs were kept
intact
the main timbers are still the main
timbers but they've replaced little bits
and pieces of the outsides over time
and they've allowed them to last and
they in turn have helped the institution
last over the same kind of time frame
another example only a couple hours away
by train
but a very different strategy are the um
the ise shrines
in japan and these uh date back almost
two millennia ago
and these temples are built in a in an
interesting way that they're not built
at a very long lasting materials then
they're not necessarily
themselves maintained from year to year
but they're rebuilt
in exact copies of each other in
alternating sites and so you can see
an image of these temples every 20 years
where
the old one is now being deconstructed
and the new one is being constructed i
was lucky enough to be there about eight
years ago
for the rebuilding of the last temple
when that that now princess of japan
moves the
the kind of cultural treasures from one
to the next and so you have the master
builders who are
in their 80s the last cycle of this 20
years ago when they were in their 50s or
60s
they were the mid-level master builders
and then you have people in their 20s
and 30s who are the new builders
all of them learning how to rebuild this
temple and in turn i think helping that
cultural institution last
itself by reminding that cultural
institution of the reasons it exists
and all of the rights and rituals that
go along with that
if we get out of the institution
category and look for some
examples in other areas we start to see
communities of practice for instance
we have evidence of martial arts being
documented back as far as 5 000 years
and that these communities of practice
are not necessarily formal organizations
but they do have a storytelling
tradition again from master to
apprentice
that has kept that information around
for a very long period of time
so one of the things that you have to
look at if you're trying to build an
institution
or organization that's going to last for
hundreds or even thousands of years
is really some of the larger demographic
trends i think often when we look at
things like population growth which are
you know closely tied in a lot of ways
to
how you know kind of growth economics
and how institutions are judged on
growth
is that you know when you look at just
the next 30 or 40 years
you have this you know asymptotic kind
of hockey stick graph
going off into trillions of people which
you know obviously this world isn't
going to support and we're going to have
uh limiting factors of resources and
things like that that are going to start
to bring population down in fact
when you look at some of the projections
around population they all start coming
down
around the next 50 years and you know in
nature we see this all the time where
you have
a top level predator their population
goes up
as their amount of prey goes up and then
as they
eat those resources then the the
predator population falls along
with the prey population and so we're
clearly going to be going through some
cycles like this so
how can we build new institutions and
organizations that are just as good
at living in a world of less people in
markets that are smaller
and really be able to shrink but not
totally die off
and so when you look at these small
hotels or breweries
or even smaller commodity companies the
ones that are going to survive and that
have already survived
survived famines and volcanic eruptions
and huge changes in market and wars and
and
and all of these things they've all
found a way to survive those
and i think one of the things that i
really want to do is start to understand
each of those
so that some of those may be you know
not very portable lessons but i'm hoping
that
many of them are portable lessons that
we can look at
for creating new institutions that can
last for a very long time
what's also important is to kind of
understand culture and value systems
we don't want every institution in the
world to last
for a long time there are bad things
that can be perpetuated we've had
you know empires that have been you know
horribly oppressive
that have lasted for a long time in the
last century
we had we had hitler and the nazi reich
who you know
hitler literally intended to set up a
thousand-year reich
and i think we're all glad that these
institutions did not last
it's always worth thinking about the
values what institutions should last
some are you know some companies and
institutions
should be fast churn and we should learn
a little bit from them and they should
be replaced by ones that are
that are more important for us um and
it's very important to kind of think
about that
as we're trying to think about how to
build some of the longest lived
institutions
so in nature we have some examples of
ways that that organisms last for
very long periods of time there's clonal
species
such as manzanita bushes or aspen tree
groves
these are species where the individuals
themselves die out but their their dna
is replicated through root structures of
them being continuously reborn
and these can slowly adapt to things
like
climate and move up a hillside or down a
hillside to help its climate
so they're not fixed to a very specific
location but have a chance to kind of
move around a little bit
and respond to climate and change and
also if you know an animal or a human
cuts down one of them
they have this chance to live on as at
least their kind of basic
dna programming code and these can last
for
longer than 10 000 years i think they
have some of these that they suspect are
over 40
000 years old and the last example is
one of my favorites it's a single
individual organism
that can last for as long as 5 000 years
and it's the bristlecone pine and these
trees are found
in some of the highest mountains here in
north america
and what's interesting to me about these
is that they the idea of them was
postulated
before they were discovered so as people
started to core some of the oldest trees
in the world
they found that the ones in the worst
environments were the longest lived ones
and in fact
when they went into the white mountains
and then the snake range in nevada and
california
they cored these trees that are live
well above normal tree line
and found that some of these individuals
last as long as 5 000 years so by living
in an adverse
environment they have a really kind of
high immune response
to change so one of the things that does
keep coming up in my research
uh is that there seems to be often in
some of these oldest companies and
organizations um
a person who tells the stories and
connects the generation
to generation within companies and
organizations
in some places that's that's highly
cultivated like the temples in japan
but in some places it's very informal
and sometimes it's a you know it's a
parent of a founder
or um even you know in some cases like a
janitor who's
who's been there for decades and tells
the stories of
how certain things survived in the past
and sometimes they're the person that
you know remembers the last plague or
the last
war and can remind current management
uh what what they did during that time
in order to weather it or
if the management is let's say proposing
a new project this person might remind
them oh you know what we tried that and
it really didn't work and maybe it could
work now with new tools in a new time
but here's why it didn't work then and
so many of these institutions kind of
have this
have this person and i think one of the
places that i found that it's
interestingly um you know very
formalized is in
some of the cathedrals in europe like
salisbury cathedral which has
been around for over 800 years
and they have a person there whose title
is called the keeper of the fabric which
is kind of my favorite title
for these type of people they have you
know roles of keeping track of the
finances and
basic administrative tasks but they also
have this role of really kind of
bridging generational conversations
and in fact i think what's interesting
about the salisbury cathedral is that
the
oldest continuously operating clock is
the tower clock that's in that cathedral
and that keeper of the fabrics their job
one of their jobs is to
to help make sure these things are
maintained between some of the
wars and difficult financial times or
technical failures that it has to
recover from we might imagine how
keepers of the fabric could be
cultivated in the institutions that we
have in the world
to help them last these keepers of the
fabric can
in some cases mean the difference
between life and death
an amazing counter example to the very
first one i started this talk with
are the sentinelese tribes of the
andaman islands in
the indian ocean and these tribes are
are small a few thousand people but they
have had these kind of keepers of the
fabric to tell
oral traditional stories over as many as
i think
what we now know to be about 60 000
years their island was heavily affected
by the 2004 tsunami
um off the coast of indonesia that wiped
out you know huge chunks of modern
culture and when the anthropologist
arrived at this
largely uh fishing uh kind of sustenance
village assuming that it was going to be
wiped out
in these islands they found them totally
intact and they asked them you know what
how did you
survive the tsunami and they said you
know this is a tribe that's that's been
on these islands for over 60
000 years an african diaspora tribe for
60 000 years and they have a
totally oral storytelling tradition
that's helped along by shamans and
chiefs and
and storytellers within their
communities that said when the
when the when the water recedes just
like it does in a normal wave cycle that
it's always going to come back
and eat at least an equal amount and so
when they saw
the water receding during this the
beginning the antecedent to the last
tsunami they ran for the hills whereas
you saw people in modern-day bangladesh
and indonesia
standing on the beach with cell phones
filming the water going out
not thinking that it was going to have
this reciprocal effect so it was this
very old knowledge
these keepers of the fabric that helped
save life
save property save and save culture
over time and i think the question is
you know who
are the keepers of our fabric i think
you know private organizations and
religions interestingly
kind of have these more than others
um i think you know a lot of our
cultural institutions like libraries
um and museums are kind of hit and miss
on this
um governments generally are pretty bad
at this but we can imagine that you know
we certainly want government data like
birth and death records
um government data from you know the
world health organization from this
pandemic to the next
we want that information to survive um i
think
the last example i'll give is is of a of
a good
example and a story of kind of a hero of
the keeper of the fabric
who was unappreciated in his time in
another city in japan
and it was a mayor it was a 10-term
mayor
in this city who was dead long before
the last big tsunami
and he actually right he pulled together
government resources and funding
to build this you know actually fairly
ugly massive 51-foot sea wall
pretty high in a city that's pretty far
away from from the ocean much further
away than other ones were
and he was ridiculed and told that you
know that this was a waste of money and
that it didn't look good
and this this sea wall was closed just
in time to save the city
from the last uh from the last tsunami
well as cities all around it who had
only built
you know uh sea walls that were 30 feet
tall um were wiped out in fact the sea
walls
basically helped keep the water in once
the once the water
came over them and it was because this
mayor had a had cultural memory from tel
the stories that were told to him by his
elders and he kept it relevant he had
enough power within government
and respect um and length in government
to build something that nobody else
would ever have the kind of
cultural power and social power
and economic power to do so we can all
i think take these examples and
try and figure out what institutions we
want to last for a long time
what is the type of information that we
and who are we going to have within
these institutions and how are we going
to empower them
to be the keepers of the fabric to make
sure
that we survive the the kind of the
difficulties of the calamities that we
might live through
and more than that really thrive and
have an have a civilization
that can last in the next 10 000 years
hopefully better
than we have in the last 10 000 years so
with that uh thank you so much um again
this is the beginning of research in
this area i hope to come back and
report back especially as i start
talking to many more individuals in
these institutions
about uh what else i'm learning the much
more portable lessons
of these institutions and how they might
help the institutions that are important
to us
going forward so thank you so much for
having me
thank you xander that was quite an
impressive talk
especially since you're just beginning
so now i want to
welcome xander who's joining us
virtually to ask some questions
xander thank you so much for having me
this is great
i am so impressed about how much you've
already learned when you say you're just
starting
it will be amazing what you can do once
you begin to actually
dive into this and do some real research
but already
there was tons of stuff that was new to
me
one of the things that i was really
curious
is did you find
anyone else asking this question are you
i'm
like it seems now in retrospect almost
an
obvious question to ask but um
was has there been very much other
research like this or anyone else going
around
asking this question that's a really
good question i mean the the reason
you know i started on this project was
really because
um you know we needed to solve this in a
way for ourselves we're the first use
case
and i thought that there was going to be
books in a body of knowledge
and you know experts that we could go
call um
for the long now foundation to figure
this question out it was just like it
was amazingly blank
um it was so it was a really wide open
space i was like all right well i guess
now this is now our research project and
and uh it seemed reasonable place for us
to do it uh
the um there there was there's been so
the resources are very scarce there was
a really interesting uh
author collective called the dark angels
collective that's that wrote a book
called um established
and it's stories of at least 12 of some
of the oldest
companies in the world uh and there's
certainly these lists that i've been
concatenating um of both you know
[Music]
organizations
and companies that
to kind of figure out which ones are
there but um but it's it's very
interesting when you have to
then contact them and the and the even
the modern
the modern management of a lot of these
organizations and companies they don't
have a lot of introspection around
how that's worked um they're very
focused on the now which is you know as
relative
also starting this project at the
beginning of the pandemic so they were
extremely focused on the now at that
moment but it's uh it's been interesting
how
how not necessarily introspective they
all are that that was one of the things
i was wondering as you were speaking was
were most of these institutions
organizations even aware
of their special age
and if they were
did they have any theories themselves
about
why they were long-lived well
i think it varies a lot and i you know i
don't want to generalize too broadly
especially
after you know not talking to tons of
them but you know anecdotally
from the beginning of this um certainly
you know they all kind of
really old organizations are often you
know they kind of brag about how old
they are
um and they that's part of their kind of
story but the
um and their internal you know
organizational mythos
but um i find it interesting how like
when i one of the things questions i
came back to people was like how did you
survive the last pandemic it was only
100 years ago
which in all you know many of these
companies are over a thousand years old
or organizations and they're like oh
that's a really good question i have no
idea
and uh so you know even for something
that they were in the middle of trying
to figure out how to re-survive
um they had not asked that question uh
and so um it's uh it's interesting one
of the
one of the funders of this project is
james anderson of bayley gifford
and and he had already looked at for
instance the
the way he had he found that out was
looking at the public
uh the public reports the kind of annual
reports of the company
um around that time and it's just he
said it was wild when when
people were um that those reports
you know as the pandemic was unfolding
they
they kind of they don't even mention it
in these in these reports until it's
like really a bad problem it's kind of
very similar to the beginnings
of of this one so it was interesting
that that it was very similar problems
that were
being repeated very very in real time
and again
to your first approximation on this very
initial look at it
um do you did you find it that there
were other advantages
to this kind of long livedness besides
survival
i mean other than the fact that they
were surviving
were there anything else about them were
they surviving at a
better profit rate or was it um
you know their metabolism different or
was there anything else
about them that you could kind of detect
that might be
a possible theory well there seems to
very much be an internal
culture thing
where the the kind of employees are
prepared
mentally for this and this management is
mentally for this where um you know i
think we saw this for
instance play out the in the opposite
way at the beginning of the last
you know big.com crash where the the
employees were in no way and the
management was in no way prepared
to shrink their company by even 20 much
less
60 you know you saw and they weren't
ready to reinvent themselves so you know
we saw
you know the music industry and during
the time of of music becoming
a digital commodity that and a
subscription service
that you know but there's you could talk
to people within the music
companies themselves and every single
one of them knew that
their model was not going to survive
what it was but they could not kind of
they couldn't they didn't culturally
have the internal story to fix that
they their you know they sold music on
plastic circles that's what they did
and it took apple and you know
eventually you know other things like
napster forces to basically just take
that away from them
um and and so um it's it's it's very
important it seems to
have developed a company or
organizational culture
that you you know you prepare people and
and um and there was
jeff bezos who who told me you know
about talking about amazon
who said you know as the stock price was
doubling i told everyone that you know
they weren't twice as smart as they were
last quarter
and when the stock price goes down
you're not twice as dumb as the last
quarter
we're just you know we have to keep
making the company that that
that uh that has a real business model
and we just keep doing the thing and so
i think that
engendering that is is seems to be one
of the most important things
yeah so i i want to um
bring in another a questionnaire um i'm
going to introduce um
nick bryce bryce sowitz
who is the um director of development
for long now
and um nick you have some questions
yeah thanks so much kevin and xander
this was a fantastic talk i've been
looking forward to this for a while
um because it's such relevant research
to so many different institutions you
had already mentioned
that uh james anderson with bayley
gifford had you know proudly supported
the work that you're working on
as has the ethereum foundation um and i
just think there's a broad
there's a broad application for the
kinds of ideas you're running into i'm
curious about this idea of
continuity as memory and then memory
kind of is something that's permanent
but i'm wondering if you've run into
situations where the continuity of an
organization or the continuity of
practice has been served by a kind of
selective forgetting
if there are instances you run into
where people have decided what to leave
behind
because circumstances have changed or
because their goals have changed
um so have you run into anybody who's
deciding how do we decide what to
remember and what to forget
well i think it's it is really
interesting um that question of like how
and but i think it's maybe different
than you phrased the question at least
from what i've seen is that you
you don't want you don't want the the
people that are running your
organization
so hung up on the way things have been
done in the past that they can't welcome
in another generation
usefully that they can't listen to the
fact that there are new tools there are
new
markets there are new situations in the
world that that is
and that is possible for a company to
retry an idea they might have tried
100 years ago a thousand years ago um in
a new environment with new tools
and so if they can't do that i think
that's that's that's
almost as problematic as not having
those stories to tell
themselves so um finding the way to
to be able to have at least it seems
about three generations within
an organization that's talking to itself
and each other in a productive way that
knows how to discern that you know you
don't want
you don't want a generation basically
saying oh you know if in even
even a current generation if there's if
if they have seen how
how they that organization or even other
organizations maybe have failed at
something over and over and over again
they might not try the new thing um and
so how do you
how do you temper that information in a
way that says all right well
maybe we're different now um and it's
worth trying so i think that
that seems to be um an interesting
question of how
best any organization can listen to its
youngest members
to find some of the kind of new energy
of the world the new things that might
be happening
in the world the middle generation to
interpret that and the oldest generation
to be giving some of that wisdom
and and put those things together in a
way that
that doesn't hamper the organization but
also helps it answer those questions
going forward
that's a great idea the
multi-generationality of a continuous
organization is probably one of the
cooler
cooler aspects of getting people to kind
of pass the baton back and forth across
time
we were talking earlier about continuity
as memory but i'm also really interested
in this idea of continuity
uh in an aspirational sense so there are
certain things that you know take a week
for us to do
and there are certain things that might
take a century for people to do or two
centuries
and if you want to do something on a
time scale that you know
exceeds the human lifespan you're going
to need something like a long-lived
institution to coordinate people
across generations but as we all kind of
know
institutions can end up in a spot where
they're in the business of just staying
in business
um and but you know so if you were
setting out for something that was going
to take 250 years
have you run into organizations that
have baked into their culture or baked
into their governance structure
a way to adhere to the original idea of
this is going to take 250
years and there's a wind-up procedure
i'm thinking about the examples you know
things like these breweries brasseries
hotels hot springs
um they kind of exist indefinitely but
then i think of things like cathedrals
and there has to be some kind of a
you know a limit to that organization if
you run into a
whole suite of organizations that have
kind of a finite ending point
you know i mean that's an interesting
question i mean i think um
you know there's certainly some types of
projects that that people assume to only
take a certain amount of time but
companies and organizations they kind of
think that they
are going to be around at least in you
know nobody wants to design a job
that they're going to be out of and so
in some way many organizations and
companies
more than anything are actually just the
perpetu their perpetuation machines
and because everybody in the org is very
interested in them perpetuating i think
certainly we've seen you know there was
um very famously benjamin franklin um
created the benjamin franklin trust that
was supposed to
invest it was actually a reasonably
small amount of money at the time
and pay itself out i think over 200
years totally
or half at 100 years and a half at 200
years to both the cities of
philadelphia and uh and boston um and
um and then also famously it was they
that organization that managed that
then has now perpetuated the benjamin
franklin trust and has ignored those
original words but
um certainly we've seen um you know
we've seen certain philanthropies that
were designed to be paid out
and and cancel themselves out and i
think when that's done within the living
space of the person who started it they
seem to actually do that
when it's left to go to another
generation again those those
organizations just become these self
perpetuation machines that um that
usually break that trust of the original
uh of the original donor so it's i think
that's
of the examples that i know that have
really just been designed to cancel out
that's
and and go extinct on purpose that's one
of the only ones i know of
and and that's great and so so one of
the ways that those kinds of purposes
are passed forward in time is through
different generations talking to each
other and having a conversation about
what to remember and what to forget
but we also have this ability to use
texts and to use records
across long periods of time to try and
understand what people from
past instances of an institution were
thinking or wanted
or you know what their intentions might
have been like and i understand that you
actually
have had a chance to check out a number
of different archives you know because
of course long now is
involved in some very special archiving
projects but then specifically
um i'm thinking of a long-living
organization like the catholic church
um have you been able to talk to them at
all about how they maintain
a continuous thread going all the way
back through their history
um well i i was uh very lucky enough to
to visit the vatican archives at one
point and the
um the the interesting so i i don't have
a broad story from all levels of the
vatican but at least from the vatican
archives
um i thought it was really interesting i
mean the catholic church is famously one
of the oldest
con currently accident organizations on
the planet at about two thousand years
almost
um and the the the thing that
um and the vatican artifices themselves
are amazing in their own right
but uh when i was getting the tour i
walked by this one room
that um that had all these really thin
drawers in it and there was all these
guys in
in like these little white suits picking
things out of the drawers and it was
actually it was that vatican was in the
process of closing down for easter mass
which is a rare moment that that the
main basilica
is closed and so all these guys were
picking out
tiles uh for maintaining
the um the mosaics of the of saint
peter's basilica
and it turns out that over 500 years ago
when they commissioned the mosaics
they also commissioned the artist to do
overruns
and and famously the artists in the
records of that complained that they had
to do overruns of all these colored
tiles they're like why do you know we'll
we'll just we'll just do it whenever you
want it and they're like no we want we
want them on hand and so
for over 500 years they've been able to
grab these tiles
and and repair and sure enough as we
were walking out of st peter's basilica
there was they had erected all these uh
scaffolds and were you know
replacing all of these tiles and the
mosaics not necessarily textual
um thing records but these kind of
physical records
that um that this organization had
thought
you know hundreds of years in in advance
to basically to solve what would be an
and totally unsolvable problem it was a
very difficult to solve problem
um that it was very easy for them to in
a way ask for that at the beginning
as long as they had the continuity of
the organization to you know keep them
in the drawer
label the door properly and remember it
uh you know 500 years in advance so that
was i think it was a great example of
that
so um thanks nick some great questions
and um we want to move now to
take some questions from the audience um
stuart brand is off to the side sorting
those questions on youtube or facebook
or any or
is in the video here if you have
questions one of the first ones he has
pertains to what nick was just saying
it's from
sci-fi action on youtube and the
question would be in these long-term
institutions are there any that can
maintain innovation while they're trying
to
not just be a perpetual survival machine
but
are you aware of any that that
continue to innovate at the same time
um i think certainly you know i
mentioned one of the
examples i mentioned was universities i
think universities you know clearly
have at least whole parts of them that
are always innovating i think their you
know their
basic model and their basic need that
they're serving is education
uh but they you know the great research
universities of the world are
are totally innovating a lot um
i think that in the cases of probably
financial institutions is another place
where
you know the oldest financial
institutions have to stay at the
forefront
of financial products and i think maybe
some of the cases where some of the
oldest ones where they
you know they might have probably
survived some of these big
financial shocks by at least tempering
all right we're going to get into
structured you know leveraged lending
around
real estate and then uh and then maybe
had suffered a very bad problem in
2008 but had enough of their business
tempered
to not have gone out of business because
of that um and so i think there's
there's always a place where you should
be i think any organization should be
innovating i think when you're talking
about you know the world's oldest
hotels in japan um or europe they
probably don't have a ton to innovate
they're
in a way that actually by serving people
the same way for generations is really
what they're doing i mean i'm sure
they've built a website at this point to
the lard
for a large consider but that's you know
they you know there's something about
advertising themselves maybe but they
you know in a way they're they're
advertising
that they have not changed for a long
time right i think there's there's
definitely a
a spectrum of that the their business is
serving that which doesn't change and so
that's
part of the reason why they haven't
changed so um
stewart himself had had a good question
which was in this research
was there anything that surprised you
that maybe you were not expecting when
you set out
well i think i mean i mention it towards
the end which is this keeper of the
fabric role i think what was so
surprising was how
informal that role is in in so many
institutions and i brought up the ones
that
where it is formalized like in japan
temple building
or um or cathedrals but um i think
it's so funny where you're talking to
the ceo or or the
the lead of an organization now and
they're like well you know it's actually
this guy who
doesn't even work for us but he comes in
and tells stories
um you know periodically at team you
know company-wide things
that used he worked for us a long time
ago and so this and it's
and they all regard this person with
very highly as an important person
within for their organization but that's
not even within their organization
um and it's not formalized and so i
think i think it's a very
interesting lesson for for any
organization like how do you
formalize this at least in a way maybe
you just give them an honorific that
they
they kind of feel the importance of of
that
um storytelling part and you know really
the oldest
thing the oldest thing we have for
conveying knowledge is storytelling
and so it's it's it's the thing that we
know can and will last for a very long
time
but um how we tell those stories uh
within organizations i think is an
interesting question right and it seems
like
most of what you've seen so far has been
kind of oral transmission rather than
anybody kind of writing it down
except for maybe those stones in japan
so
that oral tradition but maybe what we're
looking for is a different mechanisms
besides an oral transmission
yeah and i think that the other
interesting thing that i have found that
is kind of surprising is that the
when you go and you look up the the
official history of some of these
organizations
because they all kind of you know on
their website or somehow you know
they're talking bragging about how long
they've been around they have this very
official history
that has that really is very bad at
telling
the the bad stories which are really the
stories that you need to understand
to have an organization last like i
don't want to know how that organization
survived the pandemic 100 years ago i
want to know how they survived the
plague
you know 600 years ago and these are
these are the stories i want to know
and they they basically they just gloss
right over it they're like well this is
you know
here's how we did all these things great
um and clearly those you know those were
problems for
for these organizations uh and and their
lessons are valuable that are they're
just they
they're either not documented even their
formal internal hit some company some
companies have informal
internal historians but they you ask
them that question like oh well we'll go
let's see if we can look this up they
they tend to not be well recorded times
i think mostly because
people are they're scrambling during
those times it's probably it's the most
difficult time to take time to make
records
and when they're coming out of them
they're really thinking forward not
thinking backward
so i think it's an interesting question
in general of how we can be better at
this
and i think i mentioned the who the
world health organization
that you know they have collected and
cdc have collected amazing information
about the current
pandemic that we're in but how how is
that being preserved for
the next one that could be a hundred or
more years out i don't know
so um chris peel another audience member
suggests a question of
wondering um whether there are things
like tax
incentives or other kinds of structures
that might be implemented by the
government
to encourage generally these kinds of
long-lived institutions and maybe
you have a 40-year investment that
is paying off in 100 years or
other means in which governments have
you seen at the government level any
kind of encouragement
anywhere in the world maybe even japan
where they
incentivize a long-lived institution
that's an interesting question i mean i
i to be honest i have not looked that
much at tax code um you know certainly
it seems that in
um in places like the united states that
we tend to
we tend to really deal with you know big
problems
more as an insurance model that we um we
just kind of assume that we're going to
wait for the problems and we're going to
solve it with insurance um in europe a
little bit different and you know
the you know holland famously you know
really is building
in infrastructure for literally ten
thousand year events around flooding
um where in the united states we just
kind of let the flood happen and then
hope that insurance companies uh will
will solve it um so there's
there's certainly that and we certainly
see some financial instruments like the
you know the 99-year
um agreements in in hong kong or panama
canal
uh but it's and i think maybe the only
thing i could imagine in the tax
structure
um that i know of is is countries that
incentivize uh having children
um and incentivize education but you
know the education the money that you
might spend
on education and the united states does
this to some extent at least with the
education side
uh in europe much more around actually
having children
um because as i mentioned the most of
the industrialized
world is now below replacement value and
causing very interesting kind of
economic problems when there's no
children adding into the economy
um so um so i think that's the only
place i know of
offhand but it's a great research topic
um right
you could imagine a government saying if
your institution lives to be 100 you
taxes are half or something just like a
kind of a social security level
um so here here's another interesting
question from brewster kale who started
the internet archive
backup basically a long-term project if
there was one
he was saying well you know just as in
humans we often have certain diseases
associated with old age
or are there any particular kind of
attacks or
or threats or challenges that longer
longer-lived institutions might
um exhibit or be susceptible to
that younger ones don't that's a really
interesting question i mean i think that
often at least the little bit that i
know
maybe more anecdotally at this point um
than i i will hopefully later in this
project but the
um is this problem of of how
how the youngest generation can talk to
the oldest generation and vice versa so
how
how both wisdom can go down and and new
knowledge can go up
um seem to be where things fail um if
if the oldest if the old generation
that's running a company or the older
generation that's running a company
can't listen to the new market forces
can't listen to the new
things that are happening in the world
they're they're basically going to miss
these opportunities
um and then the same thing can go the
other way if the if the
generation can't listen to the old
generation
then um then they they might not they
might keep making you know repeat a
mistake that could be fatal to
an organization um so i think um i think
that's the that's probably the first
thing that i've i've found so far but
interesting question right yeah well i
mean but it's i think there's you know
there's always a case for forgetting on
some level you don't
if if the only thing you know is how
something has not worked
you may not ever try it again um and so
i think that's a
that's a that's a real problem that is
worth thinking about how you
temper that kind of information within
an organization so
one of the ones i was one of the things
i was wondering is if there was any kind
of
lateral communication between
longer-lived institutions whether any of
them were exchanging
or realizing again that they were part
of a community in any sense
of where they were sharing what they've
learned david
grossoff was wondering if
in the way that the dalai lama was
trying to
pass on transmitting information in the
diaspora whether there was in
other institutions some sense of well
we've lasted this long
how have you done it and so is there is
there any sense of them even
communicating with other long-lived
organizations
um surprisingly it seems very very
limited to my knowledge and they
um they often kind of very much live
within a bubble and i think they have
this kind of feeling of like all right
we've been around for
600 years like who do you know what do
we need to who do we need to really talk
to we're
pretty much you know outlast i mean one
of the one of the organizations i
mentioned was the
you know the temple uh complex at ise in
japan and
and i think was talking with their own
their historian
and apparently they they were approached
to become a unesco award world heritage
site and you know they're
over 1600 years old if at minimum and
and so you know their response was like
why do we care about this
you know 50 year old organization that
might tell us that we're important
you know once once unesco is 1600 years
like come back to us and
and and maybe we'll listen so i think it
was uh it was it was interesting
um to hear that there's there's one
organization that i know of that's
it's it's it's very um informal
which is a french it was french founded
of family-run businesses that have
lasted
over 200 years uh around the world and
um
and several organizations have or
several mostly companies family-run
companies
have are members of that and i'm
forgetting the name of it it's a french
name
um but um they do they apparently talk
to each other and sometimes have
meetings or at least
get together um and and pay attention to
each other
so maybe this is a last question to to
wrap up with but
the law now foundation itself is now 25
years
old we think of ourselves in our first
quarter a quarter
of being a quarter century
you've done this research what have you
come back
to take back from that to change the way
that you
want to run the long now foundation at
this director what
is there a specific lesson that you
thought um we really should do here
this this this is something that that we
should be doing
um well i mean you actually mentioned it
i think the um
the the thing that has come out of this
research in a way it was inspired by
these temples that are rebuilt every 20
years in japan is this
you need to ha i think formalize a
refreshing cycle
where the generation that you know after
25 years it's roughly you know a human
generation in a way
is is says all right well what dna do we
want to bring with us
and what and how do we want that to
instruct the next
25 or 20 or you know whatever it is
whatever your cycle is
how do we want that to instruct but not
limit um and so we want it you know we
want that
that's what we're kind of doing right
now at long now at 25 years is
you know the founders had a you know
came from a time you know
started in the mid 90s very optimistic
technological time
and you know it's certainly become a
less optimistic technological time now
um but how do we how do we take that dna
make it inspiring to another generation
but not over limit that problems because
you want new
people to come in who are interested in
solving new problems
um what is the next ten thousand year
clock project the next rosetta project
um that is going to be really
interesting as we finish some of these
other projects and that's that to me is
the big challenges
is not becoming too too limiting in the
information we hand off
but giving people enough framework that
they feel empowered to do
new and amazing things you often talk
about trusting the future
in in a certain sense and that seems
like part of what
you want to do with a long-lived
institution is in some ways
transmit that trust forward and that
faith in the next generation
indeed i think i mean trusting the
future i think that's a key kind of
both preserving optionality and trusting
the future is something that has
has really emerged over the whole time
that we've been at long now is that
if you're making any decisions that that
limit the next generations
more than than open possibility for them
you're probably
not helping that generation like you
they are going to have more information
about their
their present than you could ever
predict about you know from as a
futurist
um so how can you how can you make
choices that don't take away their
optionality as
uh seems to be a really important
principle and i know that you're
really waiting for the covid period to
pass
so you can get out and begin to visit do
you have
a specific approach or plan to
answer some of these questions and can
maybe the people in the audience
in some ways help is there some way that
anyone who's interested in this could
participate in this
certainly i mean i'm i'm always open to
look for um
to you know new interesting examples for
this um
and connections it seems it's in many
cases it's very difficult to kind of get
to the right person in some of these
organizations
that will talk to you about this and so
i've been hiring
researchers in different countries to
start making kind of doing the research
within
those countries and then hopefully
starting to make some of those
connections that
i can go and interview them because i
think i think i'm going to find
very interesting things when i visit
physically when i talk to these people
um physically and um
i i think i'm going to get again a lot
better information than i get from
official histories that you might
get you know reading a website or or
something like that i've already been
getting some good ideas
um you know to read things like um in
some cases
the the company reports from that time
that were officially the reports from a
time of great shock or change
um and um and kind of see how
the that company organization talked
about it but there's there seems to be
very spotty records around those times
so
i'm hoping if i go there i might get uh
be able to you know open a shoe box
that's been
at the bottom of someone's desk for a
long time and and and pull out some
letters that might
shed a little bit more light into it
well xander i wish you
and we all wish you the best of success
in your investigation and trying looking
at this systematically
i think it would be a great service to
the long now and our
interest in fostering long-term thinking
so thank you for this fantastic talk i
learned so much
which i had no idea about um we really
appreciate your
being here thank you so much well it was
you know it's obviously it was great to
be on the other side of the chair for
uh for one of these talks and uh thank
you for hosting
and looking forward to some of the
future talks that long now it was fun to
present here
and i thank uh members and other
audience who are joining us for this
talk of the
um thinking long term and we hope that
you can join us in another
seminar for long-term thinking thank you
[Music]
you